hey Dr Burke here in this short little
video we want to talk about a great
success so um we're going to talk about
blood pressure now before we get started
I want to just let you know we're not
making any claims to cure blood pressure
any medical diseases what I do is I like
to work with the person's medical doctor
as a kind of a team to work on the
nutrition part to help them increase
health so then they can reduce the
medication so now um you were on some
medications uh tell us a little bit
about medications you're on and your
blood pressure was pretty high right yes
I was uh
taking
Lipitor beta blocker and norx and I
forget the other on it was a concoction
of few different medications basically
very high blood pressure 160 by
110 and uh since I've been coming to you
and seeing uh but now for for a while I
you introduced me to D3 and K2 uh and uh
when I started to do that along with the
kale juice and all that uh my blood
pressure kept on going down and my
physician uh kept on reducing the dosage
uh of the medication that I was taking
and actually I'm completely off the
medication and I actually have low blood
pressure at some times uh just came off
of the month of uh fasting in which it
was little difficult to take the d and
the D3 and K2 uh maybe transposing the
numbers but in any event I'm back on
track uh and I'm taking four and four
every day and my blood pressure is
completely normal uh I would say about
120 by 75 which is remarkable even with
the medication I was taking I was
135 130 by 80 85 but now without
medication I am even lower wow that
that's interesting because um you know
the medication obviously was not working
your wife is a radiologist and I'm sure
she was happy that you're kind of
reducing your medications but I want to
explain what K2 is and D3 um vitamin D3
and K2 um don't directly fix blood
pressure what they do is they help
mobilize calcium in the arteries and
brings me to yeah I'm GNA I'm going to
get to that and so the calcium that
plugs up the pipes sort to speak the
vessels and it makes it more like
hardened arteries the blood pressure go
up because they um K2 and D3 um and I
like to do like four of each per day I I
like the D3 to be 10,000 IUS and the K2
to be at 100 micrograms and take four of
each in the morning and then what
happens is that um it starts to mobilize
calcium out of the vessels not just the
heart valves and the blood vessels but
the arteries through the the corate to
the neck up into the brain because you
had a problem when you tilt your neck
back remember you actually had pain yeah
uh I could not do this and I could not
lie
down and look up and the whole uh you
know I I used to the the the ceiling
would be uh turning and I don't have
that problem and the only thing I'm
doing different is really taking these
three and you had predicted that that
that's what triggered actually uh you
putting me on those things and
also inside of my teeth uh I just had my
uh
hygienist she felt that I had a lot more
of calcium or
deposits on my inside of the DN and now
I'm going every 3 months so there was
certainly uh a surplus of calcium
buildup which your my body apparently
was releasing and it was sticking to my
teeth what what happens is that um K2
helps mobilize calcium out of the wrong
place and and it helps get it out of the
system if there's an excess amount and
sometimes it can come out through the
pores of your body I've had even someone
coming of the deer Ducks but most of the
time it just goes into the bone so um
yeah so anything like soft tissue
calcium uh arthritis btis tontis blood
pressure um calcium buildup in the
joints where you're really stiff can
clear up with these two n nutrients so
it's it's um it's such a no-brainer I
think within the next three four years
you're going to see a lot of people
doing this combination because it
handles so many issues with people I
mean as people get older they turn into
a stone they become very very stiff and
they get heart problems women that take
calcium without the K2 and the D3 end up
with a lot of problems with the heart so
um even the medication for blood
pressure one of the medications is
calcium channel blockers what's that
that is a medication that get the
calcium out of the heart right now
they're doing even a better scan for um
for the heart which is a calcium Scan
they look for plaing calcium which is
much better than so cholesterol is a
whole different thing over here but
calcium is a a more important indicator
right now for overall health so I just
wanted to say this is awesome and thank
you for sticking to it and your success
and I wish you the best in the future
thank you very much you're
welcome